DANIEL FRIEDMAN: Hello and welcome. This is ActInf lab
Livestream number 32.1. It's January 10,
2023. We're here with Adam Pease,
and we will be hearing a presentation
followed by a discussion. So Adam,
thank you very much for joining today.
Looking forward to this and off to you.
ADAM PEASE: Okay, thanks very much for having me.
Looking forward to presenting a few bits
of initial research as well as some
background on long term ongoing research
into understanding language and trying
to mimic some just some elements of
human thought. Everything I do is open
source. So I've got some links for you
there. I also have a pretty active
YouTube channel, although it's been a
little quiet lately, so there's a lot of
material here that I won't be able to go
into in depth and so eager to answer
questions when we get to the question
period. And also would encourage folks
to take a look at that channel where
there's longer video format
presentations about a whole host of
topics that we'll probably touch on
today. So I have a large
ontology. I'll explain in a minute what
I mean by an ontology. That's called
sumo. And I'm also going to
coherence some work that Facebook has
done called their baby corpus. So that's
the background for the cartoons that I'm
showing you. The main
topic that I want to cover today is the
notion of common sense auto
communication. My objective is to be
able to make statements in human natural
language, just in English at the moment,
ask questions also in natural language
and get answers, but get answers with
exploration, something that Modern
question answering systems that we hear
about each day in the popular press are
generally not capable of doing. You
might get an answer, but you don't know
why, and knowing why and understanding
an explanation is very important.
So we're not talking about just
information retrieval, we're not talking
about Google, where you ask a question
and you get a list of documents in which
there might be an answer or even
Google's occasional capabilities for
very specific sorts of questions where
they give you an answer but they'll
never tell you why. It's more like you
ask, what's the weather Coda? You get a
nice concise link to the weather, but
you won't get an explanation for why the
weather is what it is.
So what do I mean by biology? Are you
meaning to share? We see the first
slide. You're still only seeing the
first slide. Okay, I'm on slide three.
So let's go back to I'm not sure why
that's not showing up, but good.
It looks good. Now, common sense auto
format, this format then instead of the
slide presentation format. Thank you.
It looks good. Okay, so here's what I
just talked about. So let me give you my
definition for what is an biology,
because this is a word that at a certain
point in recent history, maybe about a
decade or two ago, got overloaded so
much now that just about anything is
called an ontology. And so for me to
distinguish ontology from things we
already had words for, like semantic
network or schema, I consider an
ontology to be essentially a dictionary
for computer to read. And that also
requires a bit of unpacking. What is a
dictionary for computers to read? Well,
for me, it means minimally. We've got to
have terms, a set of terms that label
things in our world. But most
importantly, we have to have a set of
definitions that are stated in a
computable language. So just stating
things in English or French that are
definitions for words, well, that's a
dictionary. It's not an ontology. And if
we don't have definitions in some sort
of mathematical language, a programming
language of some sort, then our machines
are only going to have the barest
abilities to manipulate or do things
with those natural language definitions.
So I think they have to be in a formal
language to nail down meanings so that
we have shared meaning. We have shared
meaning between people that agree to use
a particular ontology. And maybe more
importantly, we have shared meaning
between people and computers so that the
same constraints, the same inferences
that people would be able to make with
these terms, the computer is also able
to make because of these mathematically
expressed definitions. So that's what
I've spent the last 22 years trying
to build up. And this is work that draws
on linguistics, philosophy, and computer
science, as well as logic as a
subdiscipline of probably all of those
three. And one reason
I'm doing this. Nowadays, artificial
intelligence has become almost
synonymous with machine learning. So I
need to explain a little bit, well, why
am I doing this? This is sort of old
fashioned AI of writing down lots of
rules. Why do we still need to do this?
Well, I'm a big fan of Daniel Kahneman's
work. This is just one justification of
many. But hopefully, because it's very
well articulated in his work, hopefully
this can be at least the start of a
justification for some of you who might
be unfamiliar with this symbolic
approach that used to be the primary
approach in artificial intelligence. I
think that he makes a good case that
humans have two modes of thought. We
have an instinctive, intuitive,
sensory, pattern matching kind of
process that's good for face or voice
recognition or making a very snap
judgment about what to do in a
particular situation that is learned
from the presentation of many, many
similar situations. And that sort of
mode of thought fits very well with
statistically based machine learning,
neural networks, deep neural networks
and so forth. That's an important part
of intelligence, and it's led to a lot
of important commercial activities.
But there is another mode of
intelligence that Professor Cunningman,
I think illustrates quite clearly. That
is a slower, more deliberative,
deductive approach where people can
explain what they do as opposed to just
give a reaction. And it seems like in
large parts of the AI community people
are starting to recognize that, yes,
there is still this set of things that
we require our computers to do that
they're not doing very well with the
current neural
approach,
numeric approach that we need another
mode of tool set for. And so you're
starting to see this keyword
neurosymbolic approach of trying to
balance statistical machine learning
approaches with some sort of explicit
representation in a symbolic form. And
it's this latter bit that I've been
doing a lot of work with and I think
it's the combination of these two main
approaches that's going to lead us to
some more exciting capability. That's
just my assessment of the state of the
field. But there is some emerging
evidence that this in fact is the case,
that we have a potential with
integrating these two approaches to
handle a broader range of things that
would look more like human intelligence.
Along with this grand goal of doing AI,
I've also been applying this work in
creating this large dictionary to some
far more prosaic stuff in data
integration. The bulk of the commercial
consulting work that I've been doing
really over the past ten years is just
looking at a software engineering
methodology of trying to capture the
formal meaning of things that we use in
computer science databases,
spreadsheets and so forth. Anytime you
have a spreadsheet, you usually have a
set of columns across the top of your
spreadsheet that has some labels. And
it's very unusual for people to have any
sort of explicit definitions of what
those labels actually mean. It's usually
just assumed that people, by looking at
those labels, if you're in the same
community or you can ask for an
explanation that gives you a good sense
of what's the intended semantics of
that particular column based on that
particular label. And what I've found is
that it might work for a spreadsheet
where you've got a few dozen columns and
you're working closely with some
longtime colleagues. But as soon as you
get to a larger organization with a
larger set of symbols, labels where
people may be working at different
locations maybe they've never even met
each other. Where there's interactions
occurring over the space of years in
large multinational corporations, that
people's initial assumptions about how
clear their labels are are usually
completely wrong. And so people wind up
using data in dramatically different
ways inconsistent with its original
intent, precisely because nobody's taken
the time to actually define things and
Beren. In the rare cases of
organizations that do have data
dictionaries that define their terms,
the intended meaning of their terms,
they tend to define them in very
informal ways using natural language
definitions, which means then that the
machines can do very little to help
ensure that people's intended
specification of semantics is consistent
across a large body of terms. We might
be able to have a human being keep a
data dictionary of 100 terms consistent
and well organized over time, over a
long period of time. But once you get to
thousands or tens of thousands of terms
it's well beyond human capacity to keep
such a product consistent you need
automation. And unless you have
definitions that are explicit and in a
computable language, the computer can do
very little to help keep those
definitions consistent. So that's one of
the big byproducts of all of this work
so far. And I use techniques like
automated theoremproving that I don't
have time to talk about now but would
love to talk about it in detail for
anyone who's interested to keep these
definitions consistent. So I have a
logical approach for the semantics of
terms, lexical semantics, the semantics
of the words we use. And this extends
also to computer science controls like
labels for tables or columns or
database elements and so forth.
And this is useful anywhere. Pretty much
anyone has a spreadsheet, anyone has a
database. This is something
that people don't realize they could
make use of. People seem to accept that
they're going to need to have a lot of
human communication to explain the
meanings of terms. And there's just
another way, right? And that's what I've
developed and that's what I'm basing
this work on language understanding on.
There's a common belief that oh, this is
just too hard, that we should be able
to come up with these things easily.
There's too much of them, meanings
change and so forth. Once you take
the perspective that there is a need for
precise semantics for our labels and
that this precise semantics is something
like definition in the dictionary but in
a formal language then it's
not just a sort of a graph or a list of
relationships or likelihoods or
probabilities.
It starts to be hard to imagine then how
a machine would just come up with this
sort of thing automatically. And of
course we have another venue in which
we take this sort of harder approach of
programming and don't expect machines to
just do everything automatically and
that's programming. We have many, many
millions of programmers in the world
now. They're expensive. It is a time
consuming process to program things but
we invest in this because there simply
isn't another way to do it. And we make
this enterprise of programming feasible
through a couple of points.
One is having very rich languages so we
can say everything that we want to say.
So we don't want to be restricted in the
sort of programs we can write.
Similarly, we need to make sure we're
not restricted in the sorts of
definitions that we can write. And the
way that we make that practical is
through reuse. You're a Modern
programmer. If you deliver some
software, you're writing maybe 1% of
the program, 1% of the code that's
delivered. Most of what you deliver is
going to be a set of large libraries and
reusable components, operating system,
database, web server
and any number of other things, java
collection classes, NumPy libraries,
if you're doing Python. The way in which
Modern software development is practical
is through reuse. And so that's the
other thing that I've been working to
provide is this thing called sumo,
which is a library of distinctions that
can be reused that takes this problem
that many people would otherwise
consider to be completely intractable
manual creation of knowledge and makes
it eminently practical because you're
actually reusing most of your semantics
by virtue of using this library.
So this sumo like sumo wrestler
suggested upper emerged ontology started
in the year 2000. It started as just and
upper ontology. So the acronym is a bit
of a misnomer, a bit of anachronism, if
you will, right now, that it's really a
comprehensive ontology, not just an
upper ontology because it's crowned to
be about 20,000 terms, 80,000
handwritten statements in an expressive
higher order. Mathematical logic
includes links to vast fact bases like
the Yago system, lots of translations
from its authored format into some of
the standard representations used in the
automated theorem proven community. And
as I mentioned, it's all open source and
online and to every version has been
open source. There's nothing that's held
back for commercial reasons.
Let me mention WordNet. So another
common misconception in ontology is that
we have to use words and follow the
definitions of words. And as we should
all know, words are ambiguous and words
are polysimous. The same word can have
multiple meanings. So we've created a
very clear division, but also
a relationship between the senses,
the concepts that we have in the world
that have formal definitions and the
labels that we as humans put on those
concepts to communicate them to each
other. And this also makes it easy to
ensure that our ontology is not tied to
any particular one language because any
one of us who's multilingual knows an
English word and a tagalog word
can have the same underlying semantics,
the same underlying real world
coherence, but we use different labels.
And so we need to make sure that we can
have vocabularies that are mapped to our
common single formal ontology that tries
to explain and define concepts in our
world and not let sort of language and
labels and intuitions about those labels
creep into our formal definition. So we
reuse Princeton's Word Net, which is a
project going on for about 30 years now,
I think. And it has also projections
into multiple languages, polish Word Net
toggleordnet for example. There's
continuing work on that which I'm very
excited because I started the tagalog
Word net back in the De
La Salle University and so it's great to
see that sort of effort continuing.
There's word Nets for Arabic and Chinese
and many other languages and so we keep
those labels in English, those
dictionaries human dictionaries,
distinct but related to the formal
inventory of mathematically expressed
concepts. And so back in the early
2000s, we took an effort to go through
all 117,000 sunsets
in WordNet, all 117,000 linguistically
labeled concepts and map them all to
Sumo one at a time by hand. It's just an
enormous effort where we couldn't have
really done it automatically. It
required human inspection. We invested
that effort and it since paid off for
the linguistic work that we do with this
ontology. Why do we need both?
Well, the formal definitions are things
that just aren't in WordNet or any other
dictionary. You might have a word for
earlier and a natural language
definition for what it means for some
events to be earlier than another. But
we need a precise mathematical logical
definition of what earlier means. And so
sumo has this and many, many other
axioms that individually are trivial but
together add up to creating a certain
understanding about the world that
without it, machines just don't have.
We need a machine to know that if one
event is earlier than another, that the
end point of this first
event is before the beginning point of
the second event. So we've got a formal
mathematical definition of earlier which
you just don't have in a dictionary.
This allows machine to do logic
inference, automated inference, and give
you conclusions and explain those
conclusions. Not a criticism of WordNet,
just they're different products with
different needs and we need both.
Also, I get a lot of questions about
what kind of logic do we need? Do we
really need a very complicated
expressive logic? It's very popular
nowadays for people to use taxonomies or
knowledge graphs. Well, knowledge graphs
are essentially semantic networks. It's
a knowledge representation that was
created back really in the 1960s. And so
it does surprise me that it's kind of
what's old is new again in artificial
intelligence somehow and that knowledge
graphs are a big thing now. But it's a
knowledge representation technology that
leaves out a lot of stuff that we would
need to say about the real world in
order to define the terms that we use.
So natural language definitions aren't
enough and we believe that defining our
terms or our concepts is good. Which
particular language do we choose? And
I've had people often say usually really
without any backup. Oh, those are the
rare cases. Well, I got frustrated with
that. So I did a paper recently,
now almost two years old, about trying
to quantify how often do we use
constructs in language that require more
than just a graph of relationships.
And so I came up with some statistics.
I'm not going to go into this paper in
great detail, but if you're interested,
I'd love to follow up with you. And I
came up with that in looking at two
large corporate brown. Corpus is kind of
old and kind of small by Modern
standards, but I also used the Corpus of
Contemporary American English, took a
random sample of sentences, created an
automated system for looking at some
various features that require in
language a translation into using an
expressive logic, such as modal
expressions, can, may, should, might,
expressions of authorship said wrote
Epistemic. Nose believes these
are words in language that trigger the
need for a more expressive
representation. I can give you a lot of
detail on why that's directly entailed.
This is not just my opinion trying to
advocate a more expressive logic. These
are very sort of strict things that are
well known in linguistics, but at least
now it's well quantified that about 50%
of statements taken from a random sample
of a large corpus do actually require
these more expressive semantics. So I
think I've made a strong case that we
can't just get away with graphs unless
we want to leave out about half of the
things that people say to each other.
And that tells me that we really need
this as more expressive logic.
Okay, so that's all the pre gamble that
was the library of semantics, of meaning
that I already have, and how can I use
that now to try to create a system? And
this is research, right? And it's
relatively experimental even at the
moment. The attempt is
to try to create a system where the
machine can translate automatically from
English sentences into a formal,
precise semantics using these terms out
of the ontology that themselves are
precisely defined. So I have at
the starting point English statements or
questions. I translate these things to
logic. I want to be able to send them to
a powerful theorem prover that's at
least first order logic plus equality,
but preferably higher order logic. So I
can handle some of these modal
expressions. There are a few such
provers, and I want it
to engage in its process of doing
theorem proving, not only with the
statements and the question that a
particular user has provided at one
time, but also this rich background that
describes the world. So that the machine
is not just doing a sort of simple
matching even with these powerful tools,
but it's really taking into account
background knowledge, world knowledge,
in the same way that a person would.
And then when it's done, when it's got
an answer, I want it to be able to
explain what it does. And theorem
provers have this capability already.
It's built in. They were designed to
provide proofs because a lot of the work
in theran proving is for theoremproving
in advanced mathematics. So there's a
quiet but significant community of
mathematicians and computer scientists
that are using automated theoremproving
to prove novel theorems in mathematics.
And because they're in mathematics,
they have a very strict standard of what
constitutes a real work. You have to
show a proof, just like almost all of us
probably experienced in high school
geometry of proving. One triangle is the
same as another through maybe the side
angle, side process. Machines can
now do this and much more significant
and complicated and sophisticated sorts
of proofs and provide detailed breakdown
of how it reached its conclusion. And I
take this as to being something that's
required. If you ask another person,
what's the answer to question X? Okay,
they give you Y as an answer, but then
you want to know, what's the details?
How did you come to that conclusion?
It's not just enough to say, Well, I
told you so, so believe me, sometimes
you might get away with that, but not
all the time, especially not for
anything that's complicated. And so our
machines should be able to do that as
well. So I've done
a number of forays into this grand goal
over the course of my career. I started
out with something called Controller
English to Logic Translation, where it
had a hand built grammar of a small
subset of English that was designed to
be unambiguous. It was all written in
prologue and I was able to create
expressions using Sumo terms in its
logic, which was mostly first order
logic back then in the early two
thousands. And it was, you know,
somewhat somewhat successful. But it was
a fairly restricted subset of English.
And so the parser would break and say
syntax error all too often. And that was
kind of frustrating. It was sort of like
what one experiences today with
something like Alexa or Google where
you ask a question and says, I'm sorry,
I don't understand. And so people wind
up self governing their
utterances to adapt to the machine. And
people were able to do that with my Kelt
system. But it's still kind of
frustrating. I'd like to be able to
handle text that was written not for
that particular system and not dumbed
down on the fly by a human, but rather
any arbitrary sort of text. So then I
started working with Stanford's core NLP
system and using dependency parse
transformations and trying to turn
dependency parses into logic. I did have
some success with that, but I found that
even as good as machine learning based
statistical parsers are, there's still a
lot of cases where they break down. In
fact, they give a lot of
metrics that look very encouraging,
usually on a per word or per symbol
basis, and they'll say, or we're 97%
correct on. And unlabeled attachment
score is one that's used in the
dependency parsing community. And that
sounds like a very high percentage, but
your average sentence in English is
depending upon, you know, who you talk
to, how you collect the statistics,
about 24 words. Well, if you look at
97% raised to the 24th power,
then you get a problem and you get
actually less than 50% of your sentences
are going to be parsed correctly. And
again, that's unlabeled attachment score
for dependency parses. That merely means
that two words are found to have the
same dependency relation without a
commitment to what exactly that relation
is. Well, you need the labeled
attachment score, which of course is
lower. And you needed to be correct for
all of these words to have really a
coherent understanding of a sentence if
you're going to do any sort of automatic
translation. So, although the systems
are good and they've certainly gotten
better from 2015, I mean, Stanford
Stanza is yet another few percentage
points better than core NLP was in terms
of its dependency parsing, but it's
still not reliable enough, not
consistent, not stable enough for me to
use that as a basis for translation.
And then there was all the problem of,
well, how do I actually take that
output and reliably create logic from
it? And that meant at that time I was
doing a handbuilt rule base and that
just didn't work in the limit. It was
encouraging. I think there's potential
if you had enough people working on it,
a bit more research. But it wasn't the
way in which I thought I could reach
success. So I'm doing something
different now. So I'm doing what
I guess is more prevalent now in machine
learning that instead of doing a
pipeline of machine learning operations
trying to do everything all at once with
extraordinarily large corporate where I
have trying to brain a system to do
auto formalization of language to go
straight from language to logic without
any intermediate approach like
dependency parsing. And this is based on
some of the success with my colleague
Joseph Urban who's been doing this sort
of work for mathematics. So one of the
challenges of using theorem provers,
automated theorem provers for
mathematics is that as formal as
mathematics is, it's not really quite
formal enough in a mathematics textbook.
There's still a lot of text and there's
still a lot of things that aren't
themselves precisely defined. And
there's also a lot of stuff there in
mathematics that's not in a common and
computable format. So for a long time
there's been this problem of how do we
take mathematical textbooks and turn
them into extraordinarily detailed
formalizations that an automated theorem
prover can handle in first order logic
plus equality or some other kind of
mathematical logic. So Joseph has had
considerable success at this and we
decided to team up on trying to do this
even harder problem of just looking at
unrestricted text, not just mathematics.
And they've been using Google's Neural
machine translation system, which is
built on top of TensorFlow. We're at the
moment using kind of a relatively old
version of that. We tried a newer
version. It turned out to actually be
slower for our purposes, but we need to
do a lot more expectation and make
this work more popular so people tell us
where we're going wrong and maybe
there's some better machine learning
libraries that we could use for this.
So this is the architectures. Now I want
to tell you a bit more about how we
actually come up with this set of
natural language logic pairs. Because
like other work of this sort, the
libraries of pairs, of your input output
pairs that you're trying to train has to
be really big orders of magnitude bigger
than any sort of pipeline approach
because you're trying to tackle the
whole problem and to end. And there's a
lot more variability. Your statistical
significance for the appearance of any
given feature correlated with any other
given feature is really low.
He has a very long tail in language of
things that are not seen too often. So
your corpus has to be very big. How do
we get that? Corpus certainly not
feasible to translate a lot of English
by hand Hinton logic. So how do we get
this thing to begin with? So we
were aware of this project done at
Facebook called the Baby Corpus, in part
because Tomash Micheloff has returned to
his home country of the Czech Republic
and now works with Joseph Urban at CTU
Prague. So we had benefit of getting
some of his perspective on this work.
It was basically an effort to try to
teach machines how to do simple
inferences and we'll look at some of
those simple inferences in a moment.
And in order to do that, they tried to
generative a very large synthetic data
set of simple natural
language sentences and simple natural
language inferences that they wanted the
machines to be able to train up to
handle.
Ultimately they used really only a few
sort of rules or patterns. I think
Tomash has said there's something like
20 different patterns. I've looked at
the code, it's written in lieu. It
wouldn't be hard to rewrite it in a sort
of more common language. I think it's
not particularly complicated code, not a
huge code base, a lot of simple
patterns, a great idea, but I think we
can do better at it given the resources
that Sumo provides for generation as
well as understanding and anchoring
meaning. So they had a lot of their
knowledge representation, such as it is,
was things like, you know, you have a
bedroom, a thing, the location actors
existing in this world. It sort of harks
back to the blocks world of Patrick
Henry Winston, I think it was Winston
Hope. I've got that reference right now.
Back in the 70s there was this notion
that we could do there's a system called
Shirley, I think it was, that did
operations in a world of blocks, so a
constrained world. There were actors,
there were a few things that could be
manipulated and the system was able to
understand very simple utterances.
Well, they've kind of turned this on its
head, created a knowledge representation
for a certain world and then tried to
generate a lot of sentences from it to
create this synthetic model of things
that a machine should be able to do
coherence about. So here's some of
the content of their questions. So Free
is either in the school or the park mary
went back to. The office. Is Mary in the
office? So the first sentence is just a
confusion element of
the corpus. It's really if Mary went
back to the office, yes, she's in the
office. Bill is either in the kitchen or
the park. Another confusion sentence
fred moved to the cinema. Is Fred in the
park? Well, no, he's not in the park,
but park has Beren seen as a
token earlier and so they wanted to make
sure that the automated learning system
isn't just trying to find proximity,
which is a good thing to include in
their data set. So lots of stuff like
this and more complicated things. Also
I've just presented really some of the
most simple examples but all generated
from a very simple knowledge model,
concepts that weren't really defined and
a massive presentation of mind numbingly
tiny variations and a wide variety of
sentences. So we started out
thinking well, let's just cover the
stuff that's in the baby corpus so we
understand what they were doing. And the
big advantage that we thought we could
bring to this is we don't have to learn
logic in a way they had a simple corpus
that was trying to accomplish something
that's very hard, which was to teach
machines just through massive examples
how to do logical inferences or a
certain subset of logical inferences.
We have an easier problem if we use a
theorem proof. We don't have to teach
the system to do logical inference, we
already have that. We just need to get
the knowledge representation from
English into logic and then let the
theorem provers do their thing.
So again, very simple world. They had
objects, locations, actors, states,
ActInf lab, few other decorations and
so we tried to figure out really what
they meant in a way that was hard
because they didn't have a distinction
between instances and classes.
So we can talk about in sumo
relationship that in an action one thing
is an object transferred from one
location to another. They have this
action of being gettable which is really
a modal. So we had to figure out what
did they mean? They didn't really mean a
modal, they meant something that can be
transferred and then there has to be
some kind of transferred examples. We
wound up interpreting a lot of their
symbols not as classes.
So the notion of and apple is a class,
but the apple that gets transferred in a
particular sentence is an instance. So
this difference between existential and
universal quantification so we'd create
a term like apple, one is a kind of
apple is an instance of an apple and
that's a gettable thing and it's located
in the particular area, et cetera. I
don't have a lot of time to go into our
knowledge representation, but if you
want a full course on sumo, I can do
that at some point. There's a lot of
videos online also, so maybe I'll skip
through a little bit of this we wanted
to make sure we covered all of their
stuff. They referred to things like
chocolate and milk and garden and
container and box. And we actually had
all this in sumo. So getting back to
this notion of, well, if you had to
define all this stuff from scratch,
you'd be tempted, just like the Facebook
guys did, to just use the labels and
assume everything, everybody means the
same thing. But we didn't have to do
that. We already had these terms
precisely defined and sumo and we're
able just to reuse them. So we did a big
table, this is just a portion of that
table, all the different things that
they referred to that we already had or
in some a few cases didn't have, and we
needed to add them. But adding the new
concepts and their definitions is easy
because the new concepts had definitions
that were based on, in turn, other terms
we already had. So we just had to
combine them in the right ways.
We didn't take for granted that we
were just using the first meaning of
things. For example, they had the word
pajamas in some of their database.
While pajamas have a couple of meanings
in the dictionary, I wasn't all that
familiar with the second meaning, but it
does exist, and so we want to make sure
we're using the right meaning. So we
also did mappings to word net of the
terms we defined so that we had
disambiguation potential force, our
natural language. There were a number
of things because of this small and
artificial world, they had inferences
like if you're hungry, then essentially
you go to the kitchen and eat something
that's in the kitchen that doesn't
really hold in the real world.
Obviously we're not in this fantasy
constrained world that hunger
immediately entails. You go to the
kitchen and eat an apple.
So we had to create some kind of some
bogus rules in Sumo that were very
specific just to this corpus to try to
replicate the inferences that they were
doing. So here's the
rule that gives the right answer for
this corpus. It gets a little
complicated to state it, but we can
state it in sumo that if you have a
cognitive agent that's hungry and that's
ant a particular time, then there's a
translocation event that is desired
by that agent and that translocation has
a destination of the kitchen where
there's a getting of an apple.
A rule that doesn't belong to be in sumo
on any permanent basis, but is what's
used to cover the semantics of this
particular corpus. And we looked at
things like being bored and tired,
which they had. They all say, if you're
bored and tired, you go to sleep. Okay.
I wish that that were true for all of us
hardworking engineers that we had that
option. We don't at all times, but that
was what covered the semantics of the
corpus. So you had to do similar things
for Board and Tired. They don't really
have weights and measures and units in
the baby ontology. Sumo of course, has a
detailed ontology of weights and
measures of units, all the system
inclination measures and
we had to figure out how we were going
to translate these hacks that were in
this corpus of things have a numerical
size, one, two or three, something like
that. How are we going to represent
that? So we figured out a similar hack
for covering that. All right,
so we did this exploration to make
sure that we could cover one of these
examples worlds. But what we really want
to do is generate a much larger corpus
with a more interesting, more varied
Seth of things that are referred to in
the real world. So we wanted to do a
synthetic text generation as our first
step so that we COVID kind of seed the
system long term. We know that we need
to go beyond that synthetic test. We're
not there yet. We're just still in the
process of creating this very large set
of synthetic sentences because we can
start with an idea or a knowledge
representation about what we want to
express in the world and generate
syntactically and semantically valid
logic expressions from that. While at
the same time, because we've created the
state of the world artificially in a
program, we can then also create a
sentence that models that state of the
world. So we go kind of both directions,
both to logic and language from a very
ad hoc sort of expression in some Java
code about what's true in the real
world. And that allows us to do a lot of
variation, but it's never going to cover
the full expressivity of natural
language. But we think it will cover
enough that it gives us a head start
where we can then start saying, well,
where does our automatic language to
logic system break down? What are the
sentences? Where it fails? Where it
generates something that's not even
syntactically correct? Maybe. Or
violates constraints that we know from
Sumo about how the world works and then
try to add those as new patterns to our
generation system so we can find one
sentence that causes a problem. We look
at the core issue of what
causes the problem and look at maybe the
things that are variable the sentence.
So we might have a sentence that's
problematic, that has some subject and
an object where the subjects and the
objects have a wide varieties that could
things that could be substituted in that
we can turn into sort of a template to
try to cover another pattern, if you
will, in natural language. And one of
our possibilities, I think, will be to
look at framenet that is exactly such a
large inventory of these things.
I've wanted to do a projection of
framenet into sumo for several decades
now. Did some early work with the
team there, and we published some work
about that in the mid two thousands,
but we didn't do a comprehensive
inventory of all of their different
frames. And so I think there's a good
project there to do a more
detailed exploration of all the frames
in framenet and translating them to Sumo
because the frames in framenet don't
have a precise logical semantics. Just
one of the challenges I think that
people have found with using that
resource. It's not anchored in the same
way that it needs to be, I think, to be
used more productively there's. I think
an interesting project there that would
have a very practical outcome. But for
now I'm just going to talk about the
synthetic text because we're not even
into that phase yet. The synthetic text
is the tough stuff. We just started this
work sort of midfall so that
kind of gives you a perspective on where
we are. This is going to be a long term
thing. So I tried to collect
all of the things that I thought I could
detail both linguistically and in Sumo.
So things like propositional attitudes,
modals tenses names and roles and basic
forms of transitive, intransitive
ditransitive verbs in the
subject verb object, basic grammar of
English, try to say what some
of these things are. So I'm going to
give you an example. It's a real example
of stuff we can generate and it looks
kind of funny. And I'll tell you why it
looks funny and what we can do to fix
it. And it's other examples like it.
But I'm giving you words and all of this
extremely early research even though
I think it's very promising, I'm going
to tell you what's wrong so far and the
examples show stuff that look kind of
funny. So an internet user traps a
crustacean. That's a pretty funny
sentence. It's syntactically, valid and
I think you can imagine an
interpretation of that sentence that's
legitimate in the real world. Okay, I'm
an internet user and I go down to the
beach and I catch a crab. You can
imagine that actually happening, but I'm
not sure you'd ever find that sentence
uttered by a person. We think we can do
better constraining. Ultimately our
language generative through using large
language models. It should be in
principle fairly easy to do so that we
generate stuff that's just a little bit
more reasonable, little more common, a
little more expected. But this is what
we've got right now because we're just
creating these templates and we
substitute in all of the legitimate
possibilities where legitimate is just
does it meet syntactic and type
constraints specified by suma. And so
it's possible for an interview user to
trap across station. So we generate this
sort of thing amongst many other
possibilities and at the same time we
generate the logic expression that you
see on the left. I'm sorry, I'm throwing
code at you and I don't have the time
here to go into the full syntax of this
expression at the moment, this is just
first order logic. So it's an
existential quantifier saying there
exists an internet user, a trapping or
an ambush is the term that's used in
Sumo. Again, remember, labels and
definitions are different. So we used a
particular software identifier
of ambush but its definition fits with
what you would expect of trapping.
Okay? And just the word that we happen
to be using in English is trapping. The
software programming language Identifier
we're using in the Sumo library is
ambush. So you shouldn't expect those to
be identical because we have different
labels for things that we may have used
consistently in terms of their formal
semantics, but their labels may vary.
So we have an agent that does something,
the agent is the internet user. The
object of the action is the crustacean
and the object of the action is
something and that something is a
crustacean. So very simple sentence,
very simple logic, formalization and so
we generate tons of sentences like this
for different objects
and different agents and different
actions. This is your most simple
subject verb object sentence and we have
lots of different objects that can play
roles, different agents that can play
roles and different processes that are
already defined in Sumo. So we just go
through the entire inventory and we also
probabilistically generate them. We look
at each of these symbols
in Sumo has a connection to Word net and
WordNet has word frequencies for each
of those concepts. So by looking
into WordNet we can see which concepts,
formally defined concepts in Sumo are
more likely to occur in free text
individually. And so we do prioritize
our generation on the basis of trying to
make it more likely using a
randomizer in Java and then a frequency
table. We try to make it more likely
that we generate sentences with things
that are more commonly seen. But as we
can see, even though internet user may
be fairly common in natural
language text, you wouldn't likely see
it paired with trapping and or a
crustacean. And so it's these pairwise
selectional restrictions that we don't
have right now, which is why you get
these funny combinations.
We can generate time, so we can have
the internet user trapstation or trap
expectation or will trap or is trapping
and its formal temporal logic
expression. One thing you often find
in simpler knowledge expressions is
verbs used as predicates without tense.
So you might have in a knowledge graph
internet user a relation trapping or
traps of some sort and then crustacean,
right? This would be a more typical
expression in a graph and that doesn't
really capture what the entire sentence
is saying. It says that there is a
temporal qualification to what is
happening in the sentence is happening
now. And so there's a begin fund
of this activity and an end function of
this activity and now is between those
two things. You have a dictic as we say
in linguistics, something that's being
referred to that gives semantics to the
sentence that's only meaningful in the
context of the speaker and the listener
here, there now, et cetera. There's a
lot of these things and we've got to be
able to handle that in order to capture
the semantics of the sentence. So it's
not enough to say there's a trapping
relation between the internet user and
the crustacean. We really have to go to
a temporal modal logic beyond first
order logic with equality to capture
this information and capture it in a way
that's going to work not just now for
this one isolated case, but for all
possible cases of these sort of temporal
expressions. It's also common for people
that don't have a background in modal
logic to sort of assume that there's
some kind of a fudge for this in a graph
representation. There isn't, right?
This is why logicians work on this
stuff. It's hard. Getting it right has
taken many, many decades of effort and
so you can fudge it, but essentially
somewhere down the line you're going to
get completely wrong conclusions,
nonsensical conclusions, because you
don't have the same strength of
semantics in your representation.
That's why we need this difficult and
expressive logic.
We have negation. Negation is another
big problem for graphs, right? You've
got to be able to negate an arbitrary
conjunction or disjunction of other
statements. To do that, you've got to
have a construct that is beyond a
particular relation, that is sort of a
contextualized relation. It can handle a
whole expression. Logic already gives
you this and getting negation right is
really a necessity in logic or in any
other representation you try to create.
Sometimes people try to say, well, I can
do that in my graph or I can do that in
my description logic. And well, maybe
you can for this one point case. But
essentially, if you're doing this in
your ad hoc representation, that's not a
formal expressive logic, you're going to
wind up syntactically recreating what
logicians have already done and done
many years prior and you're going to
sort of discover these things on a point
by point basis instead of just getting
them right from the start. So encourage
people to use a representation that can
handle the full complexity of the
semantics of English and only a higher
order logic will give you that. So
here's a case where the internet user
doesn't trap a crustacean on negating,
this entire complex existentially
quantified expression that includes a
temporal Coda logic expression within
it. What if I have an agent?
Patrick desires that the internet user
trap across station pretty common to see
in news texts. Kevin McCarthy said
he believes that the next vote for
speaker will be successful.
Bolsonaro desires that he be
the leader of the country again. These
are very common expressions in
natural language. They're not infrequent
and they're difficult and they require
this sort of expressive logic and that's
the sort of thing that we're handling.
We're able to generate this stuff and
have a representation that handles it
and then maybe, if we're lucky, have a
therapeutic that can handle it. Higher
order logic. Therapeutic is still
difficult and somewhat experimental,
and so that's a parallel line of
research. But we're not sort of hand
waving away this problem. We're not
imagining it doesn't exist or imagining
that we can really handle all this
complexity and language without this
additional set of computational support
that we believe is, in fact, really
required. So here
just making the logic and the sentence
more and more difficult. The Plumber
knows that Patrick desires that the
internet user traps and crustacean
pretty artificial sounding sentence,
admittedly but not all such
constructs for sentences are that
rare. You do get a news report,
the New York Times reported that the
speaker desires that this bill
pass without further amendment. That
would not be a particularly unusual
sentence and yet it follows exactly this
pattern.
So one of the things that we need to do
and if anyone is at all intrigued by
this work and thinking well, how can I
contribute? Which would be wonderful,
here is the great way to do that one
thing that we need that
needs to be added to sumo and yet is
also fairly well constrained in terms of
the complexity of the underlying axioms
that need to be expressed. So it's
possible to make these fairly formulaic
and in fact the use that we make of them
inside my Java code that generates logic
language pairs is very formulaic and
we'll look for only axioms that
are of a very particular restricted
force in order to do its restriction of
which sentences get generated. We have
this notion of capability, a capability
relation in sumo so it says that some
kind of thing is capable of performing
some kind of role in some kind of
action. So ears are capable of
hearing, guns are capable of shooting
and we have to talk about things that
might happen in order to restrict the
sentences that we generate. We'd like to
be able to say that John can't
be eating a boat dock, we might generate
something like that now but we want to
be able to restrict eating to have an
object transferred or a resource that
is only food, ideally food for that
particular animal. So we want Termites
to be able to eat boat docks, but we
don't want Bob the Plumber to be able to
eat a boat dock. And we
have a lot of processes and we have a
lot of objects. In sumo. And so creating
an inventory of these different
capability expressions would eliminate,
I think, a lot of the kind of funny
sounding sentences we generate now.
That said, I think it's not catastrophic
that we have some of these funny
sentences because remember that we're
ultimately trying to go from organically
occurring natural language text in the
wild in order into arbitrary logic
expressions. So the fact that we have
other sentences that kind of have a
similar form but don't really make a lot
of common sense may not be a big issue
because as long as we have enough
examples of things, that are reasonable,
that do cover the vocabulary we care
about, that do have reasonable
selectional restrictions that will still
enable us to translate the good stuff
that occurs the sensible sentences into
sensible logic expressions and the fact
that we have a corpus of translations
where the translation is reasonable but
the core sentence is kind of bogus. May
just be background noise. We may be able
to get away with that. But even if that
proves not to be a problem it still
would be better for us to have in Sumo
these capability expressions just to add
to our knowledge of how the world works.
So if anybody is intrigued by this, I'd
love to help you get started because I
think it would be not too hard to do and
would be of great value to the project.
So we have a lot, as I've said, I've
said a couple of times now, we have a
lot of processes, we have a lot of
objects. What do I mean by a lot? Well,
here's just a segment of the
natural language comments on a portion
of the hierarchy, starting from the top.
Here are all the process types. In suma,
we have 1300 of them at last count and
here are a number of them.
So in a lot of sentences we don't
restrict what processes can hold for a
given sentence. And we'd like to have
again these selectional restrictions
based on capability expressions for the
type of objects that can participate in
the types of processes, so that we don't
get silly stuff.
For each of these processes we have
mappings to verbs and word net. So
that's what allows us to cycle to
iterate through all the process types
and still generate a sentence, not using
the labels in Sumo, but rather using the
labels, the legitimate words in the word
net dictionary. So for example, for
Ambush it's mapped to a particular
numbered senseet a collection of
synonyms, collection of synonymous words
in WordNet that linguistically
identifies a sense in English. And so we
have ambush that's mapped to since that
blah blah blah 926, it has a
certain definition, has a certain set of
synonyms ambush, god, ambush, lying in
wait and a trap. And that's why we saw
trapping earlier. The internet user
traps a crustacean that was exactly this
equivalent symbol sunset. For ambush we
have lots of case rules. So these are
the ways in which entities can
participate in events. There are some
simple systems, including some simple
systems in linguistics. If you look at,
I think Verbelen has some of this set
of restrictions. So agent, patient,
instrument, resource, these are very
common and you'll also see
agent, zero agent one, sometimes as
labels in semiformal linguistics,
talking about the roles that entities
play in activity.
And so occasionally I've gotten this
question, which I think is funny, is
like, well, why isn't it enough to have
just agent, patient and instrument?
Well, yes, that does cover, at a high
level, maybe exhaustively the roles
that things can play. I mean, James
Pustiovsky also has this set of qualia
relations. This is a common,
I think, approach in linguistics to try
to explain language through a small
number of covering predicates or
abstractions. And while that might be
fine for abstract linguistics in
practice, there's a lot more that we can
say about the world, about how things
interact in events that happen. And so
we've come up with 67 of them. And I
think this is, you know, many orders of
magnitude too small, but it's a good
start. It's the stuff that we've found
that's been useful over the years.
So invading virus catalyst broker
enjoys reagent all of these relations.
Many of them are subrelations of things
like agent and patient and instrument
and resource, but they're more specific.
They entail different additional
knowledge when they're used. And it's
knowledge which fits with our knowledge
of the real world.
We have lots of objects. So here's just
the corpuscular objects, things that are
not substances, that hae Parr,
and we have 930 of them. A lot of them
are content bearing objects or things
that might have writing or symbols on
them that are common in our world, as
well as organic objects like organisms.
There's a lot of these, and they all
play different roles in different
activities. Here are some of the roles
that human beings or agents can play.
You can have a certain profession. You
can be a plumber or a programmer, and
you can switch freely from one to the
other. This past weekend and made my
toilet breaks and I have to be a
plumber. Today I'm a programmer.
Maybe tonight I will be teaching a
course, and so I'll be a lecturer.
These different roles are free and
flexible and large, and they also are
temporarily qualified, right? You can
play different roles at different times.
So it's not enough to say, as WordNet
unfortunately does, as a linguistic
product, that a subtype of human is
plumber. Well, you can be a plumber one
time and not be a plumber another time,
and that doesn't mean you cease to be a
human. It's a bad relation to have
formally, although it's a reasonable
relation to have linguistically,
because you can do the substitution test
that linguists do of substituting,
say, a superclass for a subclass. And it
works in a lot of sentences, but it
doesn't work formally, doesn't work in
logic. So we need to separate out these
rules and say that they're transient,
temporally qualified rules that people
can have. So we can generate against
bogus stuff like Robert Kills a boat
dock. It doesn't really make any sense?
It makes sense syntactically, but we
need these capability restrictions to
handle them. And a lot of times we do
have restrictions, like the rule below
here. But I can't
afford to do theorem proving while I'm
doing generation. If I need to generate
a 1 TB corpus of language logic pairs,
I can't prove the truth of every
sentence. This would take many years
just to do one run of the generation
system. I've got to find a way to
optimize that. And the way to optimize
it is just to look at capability
expressions, even though the following
rule that I'm showing up here says that
a killing has to have an object that's
an organism and a boat doc is not an
organism. So this would be trapped if I
could do theoremproving for everything I
generate. But I just don't have time.
So I need to use this more restrictive
form that I can turn into a sort of a
lookup table and make run much faster.
Okay? So I need this following
expression that if there's a capability
of killing the killing event, only the
patient has to be an organism. If it's
the patient or the object of the killing
event, it must be an organism.
I also had the question of how much is
too much? Right now I am able to
generate, say, a terabyte corpus in the
span of a couple of hours and then train
on it. Training takes about 20 hours on
a multi GPU, fairly beefy server.
How much is too much? I don't have a
sense of that. Hohwy much is it too
little? We're getting good fidelity.
We break things up in the standard train
test split
and we get good metrics. We get a
perplexity score that's down around
1.11.2. That's one reasonable measure
for the fidelity of your deep neural
network training approach. But is that
good enough? I don't know yet. We just
need to do a lot more experiments. So we
have about 100 names that we use. We
have a corpus of common human names. We
have about these 300 roles. We have lots
of different propositional attitudes,
each of which could be negated. We have
modals like can, may, should that are
also formally expressed in our modal
logic. Those in turn, could be negated.
We have 400 different sorts of roles
like plumber and teacher, 1300
processes. Those in fast could be
negated. And we have past, present,
future, and then the progressive tents
for each of those. All of those
possibilities, we've got 930 direct
corpuscular objects. And then we've got
substances which I haven't listed on
here. We've got lots of substances like
water or gasoline, 67 case rules.
And again, 930 of those same corpuscular
objects that can be indirect objects.
And then I've also added a bunch of
politeness expressions like can I may,
I should do the following so a lot
of these modal expressions can become
politeness. So please. May I? Et cetera.
So we can handle stuff in chatbot or
conversational, kind of stuff that's
very commonly seen. So I did an
inventory of stuff that a lot of the
chat bots use for their sentence
patterns to make sure we cover that.
But a lot of these combinations are
nonsense, so I've got to somehow Parr it
down. If not if it's not a problem in
terms of creating a lot of junk that can
otherwise get ignored when I'm
translating a sentence, at the very
least, it slows down training. And so as
I make the corpus larger, I have to pare
down the nonsense just so that my
training phase is possible, because I
don't have the resources of OpenAI to
spend $3 million a month on running
their chat GPT for the world, right?
I've got to run on one server that my
friend and Prague has access to.
So there's lots more that I can still
do. Units and measures. I've only begun
starting to do that. I've got a little
bit of that. So I can say Bob
puts three birds in his wagon
or 3 of steak in his
jar, something of that sort,
because we've got a whole set of I think
there are about 60 different system
international units and Sumo has them
all. And then, of course, your values
can be within all sorts of different
ranges. We've got logical combinations
of sentences that I could generate. So
Bob goes to the store and Bob buys
cookies. We can temporarily qualify
all of these things. I've got a little
bit of that already. So Bob goes to the
store on Tuesday, bob goes to the store
on January 27 of 2003.
We have a bit of an issue that a lot of
these case rules require different
prepositions, so I don't have those
working correctly. I need to actually do
a whole set of patterns that are a
little fragment of framenet, if you
will, for different action types and
which particular prepositions are
historically used. So you get in the
car, you get on the boat, you go to the
station. I don't handle all of those
correctly. Things we can do, like with
more than one agent right now. Agents
are always singular in my examples. We
can certainly have Jack and Jill go up
the hill. And not just Jack. I have now
just implemented quotes for said so we
can handle this common form for news
reports or novels or what have you.
Lots more things that can be done to
make this a more comprehensive corpus.
Long before I run out of stuff to do, I
can cover a lot larger portion or subset
of English.
So here's just some detail on how we run
the model. I just got a script. It's not
too hard, it just takes a long time. So
culture work. Once I get done exhausting
the set of things I can think of that I
can do, then we need to start seeing
where it fails on natural text. A big
thing to do is to use either word to VEC
or some large language model, maybe as a
way to tear down the number of
nonsensical combinations along with my
preferred approach of having a lot more
capability. Sentences which will then
add to the understanding, the competence
of this core model regardless of whether
we're trying to do language
understanding or some other kind of
project. And I really want to do a
comprehensive test on the baby corpus to
just see if I can do better. If I'm not
learning and teaching a machine learning
system how to do inference, but using a
system that already knows how to do
inference, I think I should be able to
get better scores. But that remains an
empirical question. If I can do that, I
think maybe then people will pay more
attention to this work. So it would be a
nice demo. Okay, that's it.
So thanks for learning about this early
work as well as the more mature model
that it's based on that's already being
applied commercially and would love it
if I got somebody on this call so
excited that you wanted to do some work
together.
Excellent. Thank you for the
presentation, Adam. You can unshare or
leave it up, and we will begin with Dave
providing some initial comments and
questions. >>>DAVE DOUGLASS: Yes. One idea.
Can you hear me now? I can. Great. One
idea that occurred to me several points
during your presentation was if you put
part of the Pruning inside the model by
creating persistent agents with
goals and beliefs, bob isn't
just a transient pattern of activations,
but Bob is something that stays around
for a while. And perhaps Bob's desires
evolve more slowly than Bob's beliefs,
including Bob's beliefs about Carol and
Carol's relevance and whether Carol
believes correct things about what he's
interested in right now. Have you gotten
around to something as charming as that?
Well, that's what the baby folks did,
right? They've got this model world
model, and they generate sentences and
variations of those sentences based on
that world model. And we could certainly
re implement the simple system that
they've done in Lua in a more
complicated blocks world, if you will,
that uses all the entities and objects
that are in sumo. That's something I'd
like to do.
Okay, reconnecting here.
We've got Daniel back.
Okay, maybe he's having some back
Internet issues. Yes, I had
to move to a backup force for
a strange reason. But let us continue
the conversation with no video.
And yes, the last thing you added
was the capacities and the opportunity
to contribute there. Please feel free to
pick up there, or I can pick up there
and take it in a different direction.
Yeah, Sajid, I was just talking a little
bit further about maybe some other work
that's going on in psychology and
ontologies of emotions, and I was just
commenting how Suma already has
extensive ontology of emotions but of
course it has ontologies of many other
things. So anybody that wanted to study
a representation of emotion for use
in psychotherapy or any other reason
would kind of get for free all of this
other stuff. Defining model of the rest,
which would, I think make that work,
have a greater impact over time and be
more readily adoptable in different
concepts because it has this link to a
whole host of other semantically defined
entities. Yeah, one of
the things that would make it a lot
easier too to participate
across groups is if it were easier to
actually run Sigma. Several of
us have tried to install
and run it. I don't know that anybody in
the active inference group has ever
succeeded for the appropriate
environment. You have some really nice
videos and I've tried to follow those.
In every case it broke down with some
warning like if you keep going, your
Windows system may self destruct. Why
don't you stop now? So it's pretty
scary. We even tried to go to a vendor,
a provider of cloud services systems.
Like Sumo et al. That provide
rigor in how those different states get
translated and mapped to each other like
short text to long text, long text to
short text, short text to mouse
movement. All those different mappings
are implausible in multiple ways without
a formal semantics the kind that you're
describing. Yeah,
I agree. Maybe I could say a word about
uncertain reasoning,
because this is an area that I think
a lot of people that are used to being
in a probabilistic representation often
have some misconceptions about what's
possible in logic. Usually. Based on the
fact that the logic that most people are
exposed to academically is going to be
first order logic where you do have just
truth values. Binary truth values,
right? It's either true or false. And
people want to be able to represent
things that are uncertain or likely or
unlikely and therefore assume that
logic can't handle that and while it
can, it's just you have to go beyond
first order logic. And so that's exactly
why we're in the realm of higher order
logic and sumo and have modal
expressions. We want to be able to say
and can say in the logic that something
is likely or that one thing is more
likely than another or that because of
such and such event something has become
more likely. So we have to make a
projection that includes some temporal
reasoning as well. So logic
is maybe you could call it a non
classical logic, right? I find that a
little uncomfortable because most non
classical logics are things like four
valued logics or things that don't just
have true and false. Well, modal logics
do still just have true and false but
they are able to describe an entire
situation with all its possibilities and
conditionals things like possible worlds
which allow us to capture some of these
same intuitions that a probabilistic
representation like Bayesian reasoning
can. I think there's to my mind
a clear advantage of the symbolic
representation. It is possible,
of course, to have large libraries
of empirical data, to have realistic
probability assessments and say that
such and such an event is 73%
likely in this context. But a lot of
times when I see people using
probabilistic or Bayesian
representations, they're sort of using
them. Mathematics is precise,
the source data is often not precise.
People are making a guess, I guess,
that it's probably 70% likely that the
following will happen. Then they encode
that in their system and I think those
things are better represented as
symbolic preferences. This is more
likely than that, but we don't know that
it's 73% likely versus
56% likely. An additional
problem I think often not maybe not in
your case, but in certainly in many
cases with people that are doing numeric
probabilities is that the numeric
probabilities force a total order
essentially. And you've got these
appearance of precision where 73%
is more likely than 56%. But in
reality, if that comes from anything
less than statistically rigorous
empirical data, then it's just sort of a
confidence factor like was used in a lot
of old style expert systems. That
doesn't give you reliable results. So
none of those criticisms may actually
apply to your situation. I don't have
enough detail about what you're doing,
but I ask you to consider those points.
Awesome. I'll give a thought on that and
then Dave happy to hear from it.
So for any given model architecture
symbolically represented like a symbolic
regression or a Bayesian graph
constraining on that model structure
which in the variational inference world
we just call Q. It's just the
variational distribution, the one that
we are getting to choose, the family
that we're parameterizing it from. So
it's like our designer symbolic model
and why the data come in.
So then free energy, which is the
imperative for inclination, whether it's
the real time variation of free energy
happening right now or it's the planned
or anticipated expected free energy in
either of those cases, for a given
generative model, given Q distribution
and given set of data, you might have a
very high confidence in something that
was very inadequate. And so in that way
it's like there are distributions of
scattered plots that can confuse
a least squares regression or you get
some sort of misleading model outcome
and it may even be invisible. You may be
able to look at diagnostics of the
linear regression and tell that some
sort of error or aberration is
happening. But you also may not like a
kind of unknown unknowns question.
And in the case of cognitive modeling,
these state spaces can be very large and
they're often trained with sparse data.
So this problem of overfitting
and conditional and dynamics
relationships so that something can be
like true and trained upon for 100 video
frames and then something chance, and
then there's a nonlinear change in what
can happen next or how things unfold
through time. So that's kind of like the
complexity of action.
And perhaps could you speak to
how action is represented or treated or
how the concept of action selection
and planning and strategy and
implementation impact? How did these
features develop in sumo through time?
I think there was more to that question.
It sounds like Daniel maybe having some
connectivity issues. That was it just
how did the concept of action evolve
through time? How does the concept
yeah, let's see. There was a
lot packed into your question. I'm not
sure I grasped most of it, but let me
just maybe make I'll give myself a
related question, which is how
do we handle the fact that sometimes in
machine learning systems, the
mathematics has such linearities that we
get nonsensical conclusions?
I think that's a fairly common problem.
So I think that the interaction between
these two models of the world, the
statistically machine learning derived
model and the symbolic model, is really
important so that our machines don't go
off the rails, as it were. I'm using a
term called cognitive guardrails, and I
think this applies well to people.
People have instinctive action to many
things, and we have at the same time a
generative cognitive mind that
constrains those reactions. We might
react emotionally and react badly to
something that sort of triggers us in
some way, but then we have another
process in our head that says, well,
we're in a social situation. And so,
no, I don't want to punch this person
that's offended me, even though I might
be tempted to do so. If we have a self
driving car that sees an object in front
of it, my initial reaction might to be
to plow through it, but the Costa to
doing so might be very high. So maybe I
want to swerve or brain gradually. And
having this interaction between these
two models, I think can address some of
this problem that we see with
nonlinearities of Modern machine
learning systems that do work really
well in a lot of common cases and then
sometimes just veer off into infinity,
as it were, and do something completely
ridiculous.
Yes, I appreciate that response.
I think it's exactly like you described
with overfitting to the meaning
and going off the rails from a cognitive
perspective. There's like the known
unknown variants as. And example
especially there's University of
Wyoming, I think did a nice paper maybe
quite a while back now, probably at
least five years back, that would
say, yes, it's a cat or a dog because it
was just training on sort of a
coincidental feature of pixels that
maybe approximated the fur of the
animal. And so it couldn't recognize it
recognized a test pattern as being a
cat, and it couldn't recognize a simple
cartoon drawing as a cat because it
never Beren anything like that and
wasn't looking at the essential features
of the world. And so machines are really
great at finding correlations, but that
doesn't mean they're the right
correlations. And I think that's ant the
root of a lot of things that we call
overtraining or overfitting, but we
never know, really, whether it's fit
correctly or overfit. Sure there's some
numeric measures that at times can tell
you. Okay, we're bouncing out of this
local minimum and our
fidelity has gone down numerically. But
we don't know what that really means in
respect to the common sense, larger
world that is represented by something
that's much larger than any given test
set that we might be training on. So I
think that having a sort of completely
different representation of the world
can help guard against some of this.
And so I thought of using machine
learning and symbolic systems together
where the symbolic system addresses
problems in the input data because
faulty input data, erroneous input data
is always a big problem. How do we know
we're training on the right stuff? How
do we know that if we're training on a
system to diagnose check fraud, for
example, or credit card fraud, that we
don't have some bogus data that's crept
in here there that might have a spurious
correlation? We've got, say, zeroed out
Fields or a field of 99. That's really a
don't care field. But it's in the data,
and there's no easy way for us to
discover it. If we've got terabytes of
data, wouldn't it be nice to have a
common sense system that could act like
an intern, a human intern working at
warp speed, looking over all of our
input data to make sure we've not
included any inputs that are at odds
with what we know about the real world?
And then on the output side,
making a few inferences
in our symbolic system could help the
overall computational system not make
really dumb conclusions like, oh, we
don't know what that thing is, so let's
run over. It might be the conclusion
that a statistical system has, but we'd
like to have our combined agent be
able to trap things like that in the
same way that a person wouldn't
presumably punch somebody else who's
offended him because they know that
that's both illegal and immoral.
Thanks. Dave, do you want to add or ask
something? Yeah. A couple of the other
approaches that sometimes simplify
exactly the same kind of problems that
Daniel and Adam have both been cutting
through. One is fuzzy logic.
Sometimes a fuzzy solution and a
probabilistic evolution agree
numerically, but in
other situations they don't. And in many
of those cases, the fuzzy answer turns
out to be way back when Lufty Zodig
defying and reacting to situations. And
it wasn't until he started calling the
logic fuzzy that people were beating on
him. He was just coming up with the
great results. Another approach
that's been impressing me is David
Deutsch and jarrah Marletto's work in
Constructor theory, where they start by
asking what can be done and what can't
be done, and what does it mean
to do something, what does it mean to be
able to construct?
They generative the notion of catalyst,
for instance, as a general concept in
systems theory, and they've
just identified a lot of things that
people spend a lot of brain power on as
just simply being nonsensical. You can't
construct that. Therefore, you're
wasting your time. If you try to work
out how it could be done, would be
done with the consequences. If it could
be done, it just can't be. So go on to
something interesting.
Well, I'm not familiar with the latter
work, but I am a bit familiar with fuzzy
logic. And maybe I should just mention
that this has been another thing where
people that are familiar with fuzzy
logic wonder how you could do this in a
non fuzzy logic. And the
challenge then comes down to, again,
people that aren't familiar with logics
beyond first order. A lot of things
we might say about, like, John is
tall. Okay, and maybe John how
do we compute whether John is tall? We
have this problem of well, in a
traditional logic system, we would have
the problem that, okay, if he's above
6ft, he's tall. If he's below 6ft, he's
tall. Therefore, if he's 5ft eleven and
seven eight inches, he's not tall. And
of course, we all know from a common
sense point standpoint, that's
ridiculous. And so we'd want to use
fuzzy logic. But in fact, what we should
be able to say is that he's tall
with respect to a particular group.
And if we can make these more complex
statements, generally involving sets of
things and conditionals that are beyond
first order logic, we can express these
things perfectly well in this
more expressive logic. We don't always
have to go to fuzzy logic, because one
of the challenges that I think we have
with fuzzy logic is, again, a lot of the
people that did work in this sort of
world back almost 30. Years ago came
up with things that were functioning
well empirically as sort of hacks
because they didn't have data about what
is the actual statistical value curve of
Tallness. It was just somebody's guess
about what the curve of tallness
membership should be, for example.
So I like the notion
of fuzzy logic intuitively. I'm not sure
that I care for it so much on a
theoretical basis and on a practical
basis, there's simply another way to do
it.
Very interesting. Dave, want to add
anything? Yeah.
Now, if we have time, this is a
much deeper question about the way the
sumo rules are written is,
do we have time to go in a lot of depth
in this venue?
Not necessarily breadth, not necessarily
a big answer, but okay, I'll just ask
this reading through the rule,
a number of rules have very
specifically asked in the first
participant of a relation
if the following holds, then the
following logic applies. If a different
set of conditions on the recipient
of action, indirect object or direct
object of a process hold,
then you can apply the following logic
and I look at that and I say wait a
minute, these different rules are
splitting off very different kind of
real world situations within the same
Sumo class. Well there's
got to be two things have to be true in
order to do that, in order to find these
differentiating rules within a single
class. First, you call those by the same
name in whatever natural languages you
were thinking in when you wrote the
rules. And second, the formal
literally the abstract algebra of these
various cases have to all be
analogous, they all have to be
isomorphic. And my name for that
situation is you're covering analogical
cases in the same Sumo class and in that
sense the Sumo class itself is and
analogy, it's an analogy among these
various cases which in different domains
of applause. Am I just
not thinking discerningly enough about
what a Sumo class represents or can a
Sumo class actually be a higher analogy?
It's hard for me to know because there's
no analogical reasoning happening so I'm
not sure you're talking about analogies
and there's no natural language
happening once you're in the formal
system. So I'm not sure why you
mentioned natural language. I think we'd
have to look at a very specific example
and then we could run
that example on a theorem proof and
you'd see exactly how things behave.
It's not something about classes per se.
You just mentioned how the rules work in
a logic. You've got preconditions for
the antecedent of a rule and you've got
the coherence of a rule and yes indeed
the symbols in that formal system have
to match. That's how logic works,
right? I'll get some specific examples
of an email to you. Okay, sounds great
in our last minutes. Here and also
apologies for the internet disrupt.
This is part of our long term journey
learning about this and applying it
active inference lab. So we're going to
keep this thread alive and be able to
bring some more informed areas of
intersection and application. But one
that I wanted to mention was to return
to your type one, type two thinking
and the way that there's a faster
reflexive or habitual statistical
type one inference and then a slower
type two, what you referred to as
deliberate and deductive that
involves symbolic logic. And in chapter
five of the active coherence textbook
there's a schematic of a Dopaminergic
neural circuit in the central and
peripheral nervous system where there's
a Dopamine related parameter
computationally that's like a dial in
the model that is controller the balance
between replicating actions according to
the prior like just the habit. So it's
some distribution of capacities,
affordance and then if there's three
options, it's zero 8.1.1.
So then under the most habitual setting,
like what we might even call nonagentic
or subconscious, then that vector of
affordances is recapitulated in action
selection. And then in a different
dopaminergic regime there is
increasingly fine scale and potentially
overfit application of the free
energy. And that can reflect like a
symbolically informed, deep generative
model of the world which captures
semantics of the world like nested
timescales and temporal priority
effects. So it's interesting that this
area, while deep hierarchical generative
models often are described as if they
have semantic value. However, that is
usually just sort of specified or only
explored in a few limited cases.
So integrating and working at that
mapping between the top down symbolic
and the bottom up data driven is going
to be a really important, interesting
area. So as a closing round or
question, what do you see in the
ecosystem and or what directions, if you
didn't state them earlier, you're
working on this year?
Well, yeah, the generative AI stuff
certainly got huge amount of press.
It's fascinating as an intellectual
exercise, certainly. And it's
fascinating to have systems
that can complete sentences and write
stories and always have an answer to a
question. But as we're seeing with a lot
of newer things that are being written
as follow ups to all the excitement that
people are showing how these systems
will give you an answer, but it's often
a complete hallucination. Right. So one
recently of saying, well, you know,
Hillary Clinton was the 43rd president.
Well, it came up with that somehow by
foraging together various texts that
other people have written, but it
doesn't make sense together. It's not
true.
I think these systems are interesting in
the way that a parrot can
have a very limited conversation. You
can teach your Parr how to say Polly ant
a cracker and say thank you and you give
it a cracker. That doesn't mean it
actually understands anything about what
it's doing. It's just a stimulus
response. Now, first there
is a philosophical question if the
stimulus response pairing is complicated
enough. Well, isn't our human beings
also just collections of stimulus and
response? That may be true, but I don't
think we're at that level of complexity
yet for our machines. And I think some
of the things that we can get these
generative models to do that are so
obviously nonsensical human are good
evidence that they're certainly not
sentient and they're not even smart and
they're certainly not very reliable. If
we have very challenging or high
criticality tasks to worry about, I
think they'll be useful in the same way
that Google search is useful. It doesn't
always get the right answer, it will
universally get many wrong answers, but
it's very powerful and useful tool when
you have a human being available to
filter out all the nonsense and just
use that as a filter for what they'd
otherwise have to do. It's not feasible
for a human being to answer question by
reading all the books in the library.
But if Google can give you ten books and
ten pages in those ten books where your
answer may be found, it's done you a
great service, even though it's given
you Winnie Lapoo along with the Handbook
of Analytical or Organic Chemistry or
something where your actual answer is
found. So in that same way,
Chat GBT might be very useful in
breaking your writer's block to help
write the summary for a proposal or a
student essay, but you certainly don't
want to have it write the whole essay
for you and hand it in because you'll
probably fail. So I'm not quite as
worried about high school or college
essays as some commentators have been.
I think it'll be a useful partner, and
that's about all. And we've got to
understand these limitations and ideally
pair it with a symbolic system that
really knows something about the real
world so that they can work together.
Awesome. Dave first,
and then Adam, what are your closing
thoughts or reflections?
I've enjoyed this very much. We've got
lots of work to plow forward and do.
I'm glad there's going to be comma work
that we can
become affordances for one another on.
Thank you, gentlemen.
Well, thank you, Dave, for the good
questions, good comments, and Daniel as
well, and for setting this up. I guess I
would encourage what I've maybe
encouraged in the past is a lot of the
things that we've talked about in these
several conversations we've had are
general, right? We're saying, what's an
overarching direction for the field or
something? And I think that if we got
down into some real specific examples
and actually doing some representation
together, then a lot of these more
philosophical notions would go away and
we'd get down to doing something that
has practical utility. That's why I also
encourage actually having, if people
do, say, some of the sumo exercises
together, because I think, Dave, some of
the questions that you were having over
what is a rule? How is it working? I can
answer all those questions and give you
some very precise experience that would
give you a real, actual understanding of
how logic works and how sumo works. If
we took the time together to go through
those exercises, do some work with the
theorem prover, and it would clear up,
I think, a lot of maybe
misunderstandings or misconceptions and
give us a real path to do something
concrete together. Because although the
talking is great fun, it's the doing and
writing a practical computational system
that hopefully we all want to get to.
As the Jesuits say, Let us descend
into the particular. Yes. That's great.
I love it. Great ending the stream.